let me pull up this uh story we got here
from greg price the biden administration
asked meta if they would take down a
fouchy parody account on instagram
this
the white house emailed meta saying hi
hi there any way we can get this pulled
down it's not actually one of ours
it was a fouchy parody account they were
trying to get banned because the white
house is actively participating in the
censorship and facebook is taking
instruction from them that's right at
this point we need
anybody who shared the hunter biden
laptop story and was suppressed or
anybody who shared it in general because
mark zuckerberg admitted to suppressing
it
to file a a first amendment suit against
facebook and the government because they
colluded to violate your free speech
you know rudy giuliani had a meeting
with him on this film on his show
and he told me that when they
got his uh they went to get his stuff
right they fbi came in and took his
stuff and he said to them he says well
well you want these and there were two
laptops and they said what are those he
goes there's a hunt of biden's laptop
and
fbi said oh no no no we don't want those
we're good on that we're good on that i
mean figure that out i mean so the
suppression of it and and uh
it's it's uh
we're at a very dangerous time i have
not seen this
in my lifetime and we've had it just
brings up it just brings up what this
unbelievable story with zuckerberg
admitting flat out the fbi came to him
asked him to suppress stuff maybe it was
100 laptop maybe they already knew about
it but whatever it was and zuckerberg
sends a signal that i'm i'm game let's
play ball and we reached out to the fbi
breitbart and they didn't reply which we
can read into that what exactly what you
think and so now it's game on so now the
government knows they can just go to all
these social media giants all these tech
giants and just say will you please do
this for me and they've every reason to
believe the answer's going to be yes
every time they should because they
it's good business for them to do what
the buying administration says and
that's the essence of the speech it's
sort of a dictatorial speech it's sort
of if you disagree with me you were the
bad guy you were the problem not just
with the country but with planet earth
he's never singled out an enemy like
this other than the regular trump voters
that is his ultimate enemy it's a
fascist
uh speech
it is a thing that if you ever watch the
movie
yeah i don't want to say it but
absolutely
1930s germany now you got to realize
something if you watch the movie dr
zhivago
and everyone thinks of it as it's a it's
a film that uh
who's the great director
stanley kubrick
and
everyone thinks of it as a love story
between julie christie and omar sharif
it's exactly what's happening in america
today my wife comes from estonia that
part of the world oh nice yeah and she
i showed her the movie the other day
they experienced what's happening today
she's terrified the signs are out there
of what happened in that and i if you
get a chance watch dr zhivago even in
terms of
the taking away our weapons and then
taking away our land but you know
they're not powerful enough it the signs
are there we're seeing um
history rhyme
but
they're moving
too quickly i mean look we are a
massively armed population they would
certainly like that to not be the case
but it is the case yes and so i kind of
you know
the reason why i've long said civil war
is because
in my mind the path we're going leads to
a president denouncing half the country
but the other half of the country is
able to muster up defense and an economy
and some kind of system to survive and
persist
there's a possibility that it could be
wrong in that it's not going to be a
civil war it's going to be a revolution
in which case that is biden wins without
a fight that people just say okay well
whatever and then the fbi starts
arresting people starts raiding people
he starts silencing people and they've
been making tremendous inroads in that
in that way arrests you know going after
the former president unprecedented what
we are seeing right now is coup level
revolutionary level they sent the fbi to
the home of donald trump to take
documents he had the authority to
declassify this has never happened
before
this is one administration weaponizing
law enforcement to target his political
rivals and they claimed trump was doing
it right trump tried investigating the
corruption of the biden family in the
ukraine do you remember trump that's
right when trump wanted to do a big
parade with flyovers and show off some
of the equipment for fourth of july yeah
okay what did biden just do we just put
the put the military right behind him to
intimidate the maggots that we will come
get you he's already said he's he's
already shown he'll throw the fbi the
former president he's doing this classic
projection he's doing all the stuff
we've been accused of doing i hope
they've done this for decades well this
is their agit prop this is their marxist
cultural revolution this is an
escalation this is a massive escalation
i i that's the reason i asked you your
age is because we had someone super chat
saying i'm 60 and i've never seen
anything like this before right i i i
try to ask you know older people all the
time when i see them like have you ever
felt it this way or this bad the answer
is no i talked to a guy in antique store
and i asked him about you know because
he was in his 60s and i asked him about
the weather underground he's like oh
yeah i remember all that stuff and then
i was like is it worse today and he's
like well that stuff was bad but the
entirety of today feels way worse all
right talk about bilayers in the weather
underground on their website back in the
day on their constitution now the
weather underground they said they
wanted to get a a white liberal fighting
force combine it with the black
liberation movement to bring down
america imperialism colonialism and
institute world communism that's bill
ayers and bernard this is what was on
their website
i think right yes absolutely now the
people see we're not telling this this
is what's wrong with the gop they've got
to talk about this we've got to give
historical reference point to what
happened now you've got da's financed by
george soros and you've got them
chase chaser bodine was raised by bill
ayers and bernard thorne because his
parents this is the d.a in san francisco
who's letting criminals out and the same
guy gets gone in new york saying in la
this is a absolute orchestrated
infiltrated thing bill ayers went more
underground and what he started to do
was infect education and the textbooks
this is what they did and meanwhile our
education i read a book when i was a kid
i recommend it
called my dad was a knight of columbus
he gave me a book this is in late 1950s
early 60s none dare call it treason by
john stormer who was considered a
a john birch society guy and they tried
to minimalize that
none there called the treason and
masters of the seat was another book by
j edgar hoover
he said read these books you never
talked politics a lot i read these books
and i've seen this incremental it
started with taking prayer out of school
no more pledge of allegiance
infiltrating education it gave the
playbook of what the left was their play
before saul alinsky and before that they
knew this
and we've let it happen our politicians
have made deals you've got mitch
mcconnell who has deals with all over
the place these guys pull i mean they go
into politics and they get wealthy
they're not worrying about the american
people this is now that's why i say you
need a george washington because in a
way
you need somebody that's going to exp
and trump was strong enough to expose a
lot of this and get the ball rolling on
it and he got
you know what about ronnie sanders what
do you think about ronnie i love ronda
sanders he's an amazing person he
yeah he i live in florida now oh nice
and he's taking on yeah i moved after 45
years of being in los angeles i couldn't
take what was happening so you know
donald trump wanted to drain the swamp
he wanted to fire these bureaucratic
state individuals he made a lot of
mistakes he brought in some bad people
and he thought that he really would you
know he didn't realize the level of
obstruction with the russiagate stuff
so i'm wondering though
tactfully trump is is lacking right
and you know even even his ardent
supporters love that he talks and he's
gruff and and you know
ron desantis has the decorum and the the
maga you know behind him but he doesn't
have the foreign policy i wonder well
here's the here's my thinking and i i
bring this up to people
i have got eight kids i say say you had
a child who's four years old god forbid
and he's very deathly ill and you have
somebody that
a doctor who speaks right who does
everything wonderful will hold your hand
while this child is sick in the hospital
the child expires he'll come to the the
cemetery give you give you something and
call up and how you doing that's that
doctor you got another guy that you
maybe don't want to spend an afternoon
with he's belligerent he's
you know
difficult to talk to he's a little bit
crass
but yet he's guaranteed to save your
child
now i i think you you need the
disrupting aspect of trump
and then desantis comes in for eight
years and rebuilds it but but to answer
your question he was on the house for an
affairs committee and he was in fallujah
so i i i i i i don't think that's that
that would be the issue i think okay
yeah yeah
so yeah so do you think desantis would
you you think trump over to santis would
you agree trump over to santa's like
trump president vp desantis then
desantis president that would be nice
that would be interesting it's very nice
but is it wishful thinking yes
absolutely probably i'm soundly in the
we should have a primary camp and if
trump decides he's going to run and he
tells everyone to clear out i'm afraid
we won't and i think a primary is better
i think it'll sharpen trump assuming
he's the front-runner uh or perhaps we
see something interesting happen and i'm
just afraid we're not going to get the
flesh out not just the ideas but what
you're talking about the tactics the and
this is something where
i think it's essential that we do this
and i don't know if it's happening right
now somebody uh which had a super chat
someone mentioned carl benjamin had a
great video called that has to be trump
and one of the points he makes is that
trump has to finish out his narrative
arc what he's what he started
with
good point i mean i mean look i've seen
and i love desantis i want him to stay
in florida for another four years but
i've seen him take it's like him giving
a trump message in a certain way
yeah he does do that so trump has
ignited a thing and
they've demonized this guy so much now
look it i i don't know all the ins and
outs i don't know um you know but i do
know coming from new york
i was born in new york i spent you know
26 years in new york okay coming from
new york i know
you know you got oprah you got people
that he was revered by
he got the naacp award right people said
on both sides he helped clean the he
helped save he helped save the city yeah
with giuliani he understood that he he
did the you know he understood go ahead
i was gonna say he uh i watched a
documentary from a while back talking
about how trump
new york was dying nobody wanted to live
there wealthy people were fleeing and
then trump tower and his property
started bringing back the cool factor
and people all of a sudden now wanted to
be there
and that helped kick it in the butt
along with giuliani of course cleaning
up crime absolutely all these things his
central park ice skating rink is an
amazing story how we got that done i
mean by the by the skin of his teeth
it's super cool just to make new york a
happening place and but they turned on
him so hard because he had the wrong
politics and he disrupted the status quo
do you know about the woman
no but i don't think it was people
should know about the warming rink
tell me what happened because the
warming rink was an ice skating rink
and this is why it's so important when
he says i just gave a three trillion
dollar infrastructure bill okay we know
what that's going to go to we know the
waste of money and this story says the
waste of government and i've written
about this walmart rink talked about it
because i was there
the woman rink was something that in the
1950s the woman family gave 650 thousand
dollars to an ice rink in new york
mayor koch and the city parks department
wanted to
rev uh renovate it so they put in
uh two years and three million dollars
to renovate this
ice rink
and
a little girl is watching from
her house daddy when is the rink going
to be ready this is three years she goes
well honey they should have it soon
uh
four years and six million dollars six
years and nine million dollars and
donald trump says what the hell is going
on here so he goes into the fray and new
york city there was a big political
upheaval about it and he got the rink he
got the rink
and they said that any overages he would
pay for himself any undredges he would
give to the cerebral palsy the homeless
and aids victims this is in the 80s and
the papers were fighting him and
everything else he got the rink
he did it in less than four months and
the first thing he said is like he does
all right he said who designed this rink
and they said well we've got this
florida guy that's a refrigeration
expert and trump common sense goes what
the heck does he know about
refrigeration so what he does is he says
he calls up the montreal canadiens and
says who builds your ring so and so now
here's what happens and i've seen this
when we build highways it takes an
inordinate long time why
well in the ice rink
they went down and the guy said uh they
were putting down copper tubing right
because they have to put down copper
tubing
and then they have to fill it up with uh
freon and then put it the cement and
then the water and all of that well the
copper tubing was being ripped off
over the years
so who was getting that and then more
was putting down this is nine years
okay
so so now what happens is trump gets
this guy and then they put freon in it
they pour the cement the cement on one
side is this high it's that low on the
other side they never tested if there
were any holes in the
but
they had holes in it and they so the guy
says to trump he says mr trump they
don't use copper tubing for ice rings
you use rubber tubing you don't use
freon you use a former brine
he saved 750 thousand dollars gave it to
the homeless this is our government
and this is when they talk about
infrastructure that's why one of the
reasons why i said okay i want this guy
in and even oprah do you remember the
oprah interview with him did you ever
see it put it up during his uh
19 no 25 years ago oh yeah yeah you saw
that yeah he talked about the same thing
this guy has talked about the same thing
in terms of getting ripped up at that
time japan china nato countries not
paying their fair pay he was always
america first he was not a globalist
and they've painted him they've
assassinated this man so that's where my
frustration is because
they've made it so so uh uh what i was
going to say is uh
it's not his politics it's sort of you
know his policies i don't think matter
all that much what matters is that he
i should say his domestic policy matters
very little compared to his
international policy
ending the wars
no new wars bringing our troops back
they don't like
that when he comes into office they say
you know the intelligence agencies will
come to him and say here's what you're
going to do now here's here's our plan
and he goes no and they go excuse us
and so they go to war with him russia
gate it's endless now the fbi rating is
home because they said we're in charge
and you'll you'll do what we want and
trump said no i lived in washington in
the beltway for about eight nine years
and one of the biggest shocks while i
was there was realizing the
military-industrial complex is not a
conspiracy theory it's 100 real and
these people are not going to vote for
people or appoint people who are going
to take away from their their bottom
line they are not going to have policies
that are going to reduce their income
level and responsible policies the way
you do modern warfare right now we do
not need to have the military industrial
complex it's the scale we do the only
politician america who really understood
that apparently was trump and he comes
in maybe there's a couple others but not
none with his platform he comes in this
is a huge threat and he had a very
minimalist foreign policy piece through
strength it was entirely effective and
this is something that is a huge threat
because that is how they make all their
money look at where all these guys go
when they're out of the administration
they go into this loop this revolving
door they make millions of dollars in
contracting and then back into the
government for the next establishment
establishmentarian administration look
at what they did in afghanistan the
billions of dollars that was left there
the planes the the weaponry the the the
the the
the i mean how could they how can you do
that how is it intentional
absolutely if ian were here but ian's
off the night he would he would tell you
that biden surrendered our forces and
and he's and he's correct biden
abandoned bagram air force base without
telling our partners in afghanistan that
makes no sense there's no way you do the
next an accident such a scandal yeah and
then it was looted by rape by by just
random people and then we drowned a
bunch of kids right after yeah yeah good
stuff and it doesn't talk about and joe
wants to give a nice little speech on
that thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there